you guys loved our XPS comparison to the
MacBook Air but many of you said I
should be comparing it to the MacBook
Pros instead because of the price tag
and because of the powerful processor
and the RTX 4070 Graphics so here we go
let's see how this Beast of an XPS
compares to the M2 Pro MacBook Pro now
I'm going to focus Less on the exterior
but I want to show off the size you guys
see that the 16 inch has a much larger
display than the 15 inch which is why we
compared it to that 15 inch MacBook Air
as far as the thickness though this is
actually very similar to the 16 inch but
the footprint is much much smaller now
of course we also have the 14 inch
MacBook Pro which is smaller than this
15 inch Dell so that is where the Dell
kind of fits right in the middle but
unlike that M2 MacBook Air it has fans
built into it to cool it down its price
tag is much closer very similar to these
MacBook Pros so that is what we're going
to be taking a look at now as far as
ports these are also much more similar
because they both have SD card slots and
a USB type-c on the right side and on
the left we have Thunderbolt ports but
the MacBook has that Mac safe charging
so you effectively get an extra Port
along with that HDMI so the MacBooks do
take the win there now as far as the
keyboards they are very very similar but
like I said with the M2 MacBook gear I
prefer how the XPS feels but as far as
track pads that is where the MacBook
Pros do take the win with that magnetic
track pad looking at the full spec side
by side the MacBook Pro is more
expensive by about 250 bucks if you spec
them out the same and if you're looking
at the 14 inch instead of 16 then we
have rough a 50 dollar difference now
for its comparison I'm gonna stick with
the 16 inch because I think it's a
little bit closer expect like the xbs
and I want to start covering the
speakers because the XPS trashed the M2
MacBook Air and this is going to be a
lot more fair of a comparison with the
front facing speakers here and this one
has similar thickness so it has more
room for those speakers so let's take a
listen
[Music]
forgive me
you guys let me know what you think down
in the comments section Below in this
case I hear a lot more bass coming from
the 16-inch MacBook Pro I mean these
things have amazing speakers and the
15-inch surprisingly is louder than the
16 inch MacBook Pro the bass is not as
good so overall I'll give it a win to
the MacBook but I'm still shocked by how
big of an upgrade Dell made compared to
the previous generations and comparing
to that MacBook Air like I mentioned it
smoked it now as far as webcams the
MacBooks now have 1080p webcams while
the Dell still has a 720p webcam let me
know which one looks better and which
one sounds better down in the comments
now as far as the displays both are
rated at 500 nits and normal use here
and it looks like the Dell is actually
slightly brighter but the resolution is
actually almost I identical between the
two now comparing the HDR footage both
of them look fantastic I would say that
the blacks are deeper especially when
there's mixed lighting because we have
an OLED screen with the XPS compared to
the mini LED screen on the MacBook which
means as different zones so sometimes
you can get some blooming but the peak
brightness is actually higher so right
here I can actually see a little bit
more brightness on the dirt bike over
there but with the Dell we actually have
deeper shadows and blacks are perfectly
black because each pixel is lit up by
itself and you don't have any risk of
having blooming issues now in the past
when we compared oleds to the mini LED
previous generations they didn't get
bright enough to really compete but the
hdr on these new Dells the oleds they
look really good and they get much
brighter than before getting into
performs you guys saw how fast the
Dell's ssds were they smoked them to air
but this time around the MacBook Pro is
very similar slightly faster both on
right and on read speed so it's a much
more fair comparison now comparing CPU
performance our MacBook does take the
win both in terms of single core byte
just a little bit and this used to be a
huge difference and in multi-core we
have a difference of 2 300 points now of
course this is the unbend M2 Pro if you
were to save about 300 bucks and get the
bin one with the 14 inch well then
you're getting a much better value than
the xbs but with that said this score
was having the XPS plugged in we also
tested it unplugged and then it drops
down to 10 114 and that is with the
ultra performance and full performance
mode enabled on battery power so the XPS
does lose some performance when you
unplug it now as far as graphics
performance we have the RTX 4070 in the
Dell XPS and looking at our compute test
here we have 91 200 compared to 82 900
so it beats out the unbend M2 Pro but of
course this is having it plugged in and
I ran it once more unplugged and even
though it dropped it dropped by barely
any which is surprising it used to drop
by half or more so this thing's very
well optimized and it's still
outperforming the unbend N2 Pro but
we'll see how this affects it in some
real world applications next I have
3dmarks Wildlife extreme for our gaming
Benchmark and looking at the results the
XPS wins again with 92 FPS compared to
77.9 so it is more powerful even if we
were to unplug it the graphics are
really great in the laptop and now let's
take a look at blender where we're going
to render this complex scene and take a
look at these results we have 29 seconds
compared to 2 minutes and 41 seconds and
that is because of the ray tracing cores
that are built into that graphics card
it makes 3D rendering Lightning Fast
compared to even an unbend M2 Pro
MacBook Pro and now I have adobe's
Lightroom classic opened up right here
with 50 edited high resolution images
and going through these pictures the Mac
is definitely loading them up a little
bit faster each time and now let's go
ahead and Export all 50 of these and
here are the results the MacBook took 57
seconds compared to a minute and 32
seconds and like I mentioned that is
where not only is the CPU and GP working
but also that unified memory that makes
it faster and an other tasks when you're
using your sliders doing things that use
the neural engine the Mac is also faster
and now we're going to take a look at
DaVinci Resolve with our standard 4K
footage that has both multiple Luts and
film grain applied now both these could
play this back perfectly without any
issues and in our comparison with the M2
MacBook Air I was just really surprised
how that with the special media encoder
media engines that Apple has that the
XPS still did a great job and now let's
go ahead and Export this five minute
project and while this is going if we
look up top right here the RTX graphics
card and the XPS is actually encoding
this slightly faster than the M2 Pro oh
it's actually slowing down a little bit
I don't know if I might be throttling I
hear the fans kicking up quite a bit and
for our results the MacBook took a
minute to 20 seconds compared to a
minute and 33 seconds which is
interesting because in our comparison
with the M2 air the XPS actually got a
better result slightly faster than this
one so it could be just because of that
throttling of course we did hear the
fans kick up it did get louder it was
running hotter whereas the 16 inch stays
quiet and it stays cooler and if you
were using the 14 inch to have the same
exact specs well it would actually run
hotter but the performance would still
be the same and now we need to talk
about the battery life and this is where
we have a big difference because the Mac
is going to get about double the real
world battery life now part of that is
because we have this display the OLED
high resolution that sucks a lot more
power but the other part is that the
Apple silicon chip is very efficient
compared to Intel in Nvidia that doesn't
need more power to get that level of
performance so if you want the best
battery life the Mac definitely wins
there and now for my final thoughts I'm
just really surprised by how much Dell
has improved their laptops and how Intel
in Nvidia has have stepped up to get
great performance in a small form factor
like this whereas just about a year to
two years ago an apple silicon launched
Apple was really far ahead of the
competition so if you're looking for a
Windows laptop I either for the
operating system you need programs that
run just on that which I've talked about
that many times or you prefer this kind
of a form factor now we have some great
choices from Dell where a lot of things
have been greatly improved and that is
what impresses me you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next one
please
[Music]